you've taught so many writers who've
gone on to do amazing Hollywood projects
do you think that a writer is born or is
made over time it's that nature versus
nurture my answer that is yes both yeah
you know they are born but they are also
nurtured that is to say they have to I
think nurturing is a big part of it but
it's really a lot about about discipline
I think a very talent is what you're
born with
maybe discipline can be learned to some
extent relative to the way that you
brought up by your parents and the way
you're taught by your teachers in the
early part of your education but I would
say the most overrated part of the
equation is talent that discipline is
really the important part of it how and
discipline here's here's discipline
here's how you measure discipline that
it's how much time you're willing to put
into this I was talking to write in the
other day who's being told that her
script isn't ready well she's rewritten
it already three times she said well
David kept koe PP very very successful
writer who's a former student here he
wrote two of the Jurassic Park pictures
a Spider Man he's a gigantically
successful writer he says the reason for
his success is his ability to get
through seventeen drafts of a screenplay
so this gun when I'm speaking to
yesterday doesn't have the discipline
she doesn't want to give it the time
that it that it takes so it really does
take a lot of time and I think that it's
harder to understand that when you're
really young and easier to understand it
conversely when you're when you're more
mature
you